[BLANK_AUDIO]
There are several means by which your performance will be evaluated for
this course. First are quizzes that you will take while watching lessons on
Udacity. These quizzes are not graded. But are included to evaluate your
understanding of material as you follow along. In terms of graded evaluation,
this course includes projects, assignments, class participation and
an exam. The projects and some of the assignments are team based. And
all members of the team will receive the same score on that submittal.
That said, you will have an opportunity to comment on the contributions, or
lack there, of your teammates. Those comments will become part of
their class participation scores. The staff of this course,
will make a strong effort to express the grading criteria for each deliverable,
as explicitly as possible. Moreover, it is our intent to provide you accurate,
prompt and informative feedback on your work. Should you have any
questions about a grade you receive, please send an email to the head TA.
Do not post a question about grades on Piazza. Any general announcements about
grading, will be made by the staff using T-Square.